My opponent tonight is activist
and author Ijeoma Oluo.
Here's what you need to know.
Her new book is called
So You Want to Talk About Race.
I can't wait for the sequel--
Friendship-Destroying Argument.
(laughter)
She's the editor-at-large
at The Establishment,
a media platform run
and funded by women.
I look forward
to mansplaining truth to power.
And Harper's Bazaar
called her book
"One of the ten books
to read in 2018."
Stop planning my life, Harper!
Ijeoma Oluo, everybody.
Welcome.
-Thanks for having me.
-Ijeoma?
(applause and cheering)
So you want to talk about race.
I generally... do not.
Why are you making me talk
about race?
Well, I figured titling it,
So You've Been Dragged
Kicking and Screaming
-Into Talking About Race was
a bit long. -That is long.
Yeah. So I figured I'd give you
the benefit of the doubt,
since you're there, you have to
have the conversation.
Might as well say you wanted to
do it in the first place.
-Great. So you're putting me in
a position of power. -Yeah.
How do I win, how do I win the
conversation about race?
You know what's interesting
is you really can't win
a conversation about race.
Well, uh, you got to give me
a shot, you know?
So we're talking about
lived realities, right?
If you say that you had cereal
for breakfast,
and I say no, you did not have
cereal for breakfast,
I can't really win
that conversation.
If I say I had oatmeal, so that
means you didn't have cereal,
there's no winner
in that conversation.
When we're talking about race,
we're talking about
what I experience
as a black woman,
what you experience
as a white man.
There's no winner when we're
talking about lived experiences,
there's only understanding.
Well, what if I ate all the eggs
so nobody could have breakfast?
That's an experience
that we all share.
I'm the guy who gets breakfast
and you don't.
Is that... ?
Well, then the conversation
really is about
why you ate all of the eggs and
you felt that was appropriate.
And that might have something to
do with race.
-You think so?
-It might.
I don't see. I don't...
(applause and cheering)
I just have an instinct to want
everything and more,
and neglect other people having
the equal amount.
I... I don't see the connection.
Um...
I want to look at
your book here.
Your titles of each chapter,
they kind of do the interview
for me.
You break it down each chapter,
what is racism?
Why am I always being told to
check my privilege?
Why can't I touch your hair?
I just call it-- I just got
called racist, what do I do now?
Hypothetical, I just got called
racist, what do I do now?
(laughter)
I would say,
first take a deep breathe
before you start responding
and say,
"No I'm not racist.
I didn't do anything racist."
Stop and listen and think,
"Someone is trying to give me
"an opportunity to learn about
my actions
and how they may be
harming someone."
And pause and think,
"Where can I learn?"
Ask more questions.
Ask what you said or did that
might have been racist.
And maybe Google a little,
because chances are,
you're not the first person
to do that thing.
And chances are someone's
written a lot
about why it is racist.
Are these conversations
happening in America?
Do people want to have this
conversation?
These conversations are
definitely happening,
but when they happen without
thought and care,
it's pretty much just a
shouting match.
But we need to be able to talk
about race,
because believe it or not,
we're always talking about race.
We're talking about it
in the ways
in which we don't ask people
what they need
and what their experiences are.
We're talking about it in our
every day decisions.
So we might as well try to do it
with a little thought and care.
-Did you see the Super Bowl
last night? -I did not.
I did, like you, though,
see a lot of the commercials.
There were great commercials,
right?
Isn't it inspiring that we've
gotten to a place
where somebody like MLK
can sell us trucks?
I'm gonna have to impose a
moratorium
on white people ever talking
about Martin Luther King.
-It's-it's something that I feel
like, -I'm great.
um, has been abused.
I will first say, write a book
report on Martin Luther King,
and then maybe you can talk
about him,
because until it's been shown
that it can be done responsibly
by white America,
I think it's best to leave that
to us for now.
Isn't he a good gateway hero to
start talking about race?
Oh, I would absolutely love it
if people would listen
-to what Dr. King said about
race. -Okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's one angle.
Do you have something else?
I know my book is called So You
Want to Talk About Race,
but it's really, so some people
need to listen about race
while other people talk
about race.
And the people who need to
listen are kind of like you.
Tell me something
I already know.
What you already know
is that race is in everything.
And when you are not talking
about race,
when you think you're not
talking about race,
you're talking about whiteness,
because it has infused
our entire culture.
So if you don't want to say
"play the race card,"
you'll start talking about race
with more intention,
so that way we can actually
discover issues
of racial oppression in this
society, and get to the point
where things maybe won't be
always about race.
-It's in everything?
-Everything.
-It's like paprika.
-Yes.
Good to know.
Her book is called,
So You Want to Talk About Race.
Ijeoma Oluo, everyone.